talk talk fast you first my name is  Sarah Connor  August 29 1997  supposed to be Judgment Day  but I changed the future saved three  billion lives  enough of a resume for you  [Music]  you may have changed the future  didn't change our fate  you're scared  to protect you  never seen one like you before almost  human I am human just enhanced  why do you care what happens to her  because I was her  I can see you're very upset I'm going to  help you protect the girl  nobody else is gonna bat because of me  if you don't make it  everybody dies respective big pain  brother whole body's a weapon  sorry  [Music]  and this is all over I am going to kill  you I understand  I'll be back  you  you